you're here Agent Coulson of shield he's
come to save us
yeah just to clarify where is here who
is us and from what
[Music]
oh hell you ever seen an alien
Oh
hey everybody we got some new agents of
shield to talk about because it's
premiering next week it's gonna be a
two-hour premiere so I'll explain what's
going on with the story what the
schedule is going to be but I'm also
going to talk about runaways after I
talk about agents of shield stuff
because that's another Marvel TV show
that just dropped on Hulu so if you are
finding me for the first time we do
Marvel every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything probably the most
important thing if you didn't know
agents of shield is on Friday nights at
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time now normally
it's a one-hour show
but episode 1 is premiering next Friday
night
it's gonna be a two-hour premiere the
episode is just titled orientation so
Coulson and everyone find themselves on
this space station here they're very
clearly being held captive by the Kree
who are experimenting on them which sort
of gives you flashbacks for the Inhumans
story in the comics it just looks like
this creatures that they're running from
is one of the other Kree experiments if
it's not a member of the brood or some
other race but they usually try to work
in visual Easter eggs for that sort of
stuff so the mission of episode 1 & 2 is
pretty simple get their asses off the
space station and get rid of those Kree
but for the most part they've been swept
up in this space-based war that Ghost
Rider teased at the end of last season
so agents of shield is now in space for
the duration of this season although
obviously they're gonna be going to
other planets so just expect a mixture
of them running around on spaceships in
episodes space stations like this one
here and then foreign planets so as you
probably guess most of the Easter eggs
and the storylines they're gonna pull
from are gonna be guardians of the
galaxy stuff just because they are in
outer space and everything's gonna get
really weird
in Captain Marvel kree-skrull war stuff
which i think is actually more exciting
like guardians of the galaxy is really
cool but pushing into Kree lore is just
a backdoor to Captain Marvel stuff and
we actually just found out that Captain
Marvel is going to be in the Captain
Marvel movie which is a completely
separate thing that has nothing to do
with what's going on on agents of shield
I did a season 5 trailer video a little
while ago talking about theories about
who this new character might be but he's
one of the new cast members that'll join
them on a recurring basis but what's
gonna happen with my episode 1 video is
this because it's gonna be a 10:00 p.m.
Friday night show nobody's gonna wait
around like a couple hours for me to
post that video so my shield video
we'll probably just post on Saturday
mornings on top of that next Friday
night the cast of Star Wars the last
Jedi is going on Jimmy Kimmel they'll
probably be a big new trailer so
there'll be Star Wars the last Jedi
posting Friday night then my shield
video will post Saturday morning but if
you have any questions or bonus videos
that you want me to do for shield
related stuff just let me know in the
comments I know there's a whole bunch of
Marvel TV shows all over the place now
because we have runaways Punisher
dropped a little while ago so I've been
getting a lot of requests for specific
Easter Egg videos and stuff like that
but the thing with Runaways is that it's
a Tuesday show so I probably won't be
able to do weekly videos for that just
because it conflicts with the stuff that
I'm already doing but I will do Easter
Egg videos and wrap-up videos once the
season is done it's supposed to be 10
episodes they've released the first
three so far the fourth episode will
premiere next Tuesday so if you haven't
seen it yet be sure to check it out it's
all on Hulu kind of charity meeting is
this
[Music]
a lot of our parents are who we thought
something really weird is going on
I have so many questions no matter what
we are we can't let our parents keep
getting away with this stuff
we cannot let anyone undermine what
we're doing
we're gonna need another sacrifice these
kids are living on borrowed time
[Music]
we have to stop this no one else will
so as you can see is very Degrassi meets
the Marvel Universe but they're doing
that first run of Runaways the comic
book storyline is pretty much copy
pasted onto the screen there been a
couple minor tweaks of the characters
but if you do want to know where the
story is headed you can just read Brian
K Vaughn's Runaways if you remember what
happened to the Pryde during that
storyline I think the ending will be
just a little bit different but for the
most part the show is pretty good the
performances have been pretty solid so
far I've only seen the first three
episodes so obviously there's still a
lot more left to come but the special
effects have been solid they've done Old
Lace which isn't something that I
expected it's a mixture of CG in a
puppet so if you don't know who Old Lace
is it's just a dinosaur that one of the
characters has a telepathic link to what
I think will end up happening is is that
the show will be fine they'll get their
second season but it'll just take
everyone a long time to find the show so
like nobody will seem like they're
watching it now but we'll get to next
year and then everyone will be like hey
wait a minute where all the videos for
runaways so we are kind of getting to
that point where there are so many comic
book shows that people have trouble
keeping up so like I just can't do
videos for everything so when it comes
to stuff like Runaways or even The
Punisher or any of the smaller shows I'm
always happy to do wrap-up or Easter Egg
videos or a character videos so if you
do have special requests just leave them
in the comments below but with a few
exceptions it's been sort of the
opposite of DC movies and DC TV so
lately the Marvel movies have actually
been doing a really good job like
they're doing gangbusters in the TV
shows haven't been quite so great like
they've been more misses than hits so
what will happen is is I'll do my
spoilery Punisher video tomorrow
sometime there's obviously a whole bunch
of other comic-book stuff going on so
I'll try to get through it as fast as
possible but usually I post updates on
Twitter and Facebook there are links for
those in the description but just leave
requests if there's something that you
have a question about that I haven't
talked about in the video I'm still
giving away movie gift certificates for
just whatever movie you guys want all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll just announce a winner when I
post that punisher video tomorrow but
happy Thanksgiving everybody we got a
bunch of really awesome stuff coming up
in the next month click here for that
funny ant-man infinity war teaser and
click here for the big
ketchup trailer for the DC TV crossover
thank you so much for watching everybody
stand awesome I'll see you guys tonight